this is Startalk all right James clever
wants to know this
he's from Bangor Michigan he says I've
been reading your book death by black
hole oh thank you mm-hmm the fan
favorite yeah black hole and you
mentioned that scientists knew there
were holes in the periodic table well
before they were discovered I'm just
wondering how did they know maybe a
brief history of how they were
originally organized so we know these
tables we know that there's gaps how do
they know there's gaps yeah so I'd love
me some periodic table just I can't get
enough periodic table just so you know
yeah so so so once you learn how to
organize the elements which is what
Mendeleev figured out okay a Russian
scientists right
he once you do that if you arrange them
by how many protons are in their nucleus
very simple weighted okay how many
protons right so just a proton got four
then you're over here you got five go
next to four you got seven skip one do
we have six yet no not well actually did
have six six is carbon but do you have
eight oh that's oxygen like give me a
hard one
good do you have nine right if and if no
we don't have it yet but we got ten so
ten go in your ten slot right well whose
where's nine we don't have it yet
we'll get get off your ass and find me
some nine and so this these are how we
you establish the gaps in the periodic
table the periodic table is complete
from 1 up to 100 and what are we up to
110 or 12 or something so it's not like
you're gonna just discover some other
element that's going to try that's going
to slip right because there's no 9.7
there's no nine point seven correct some
aspects of science are complete that's
it week that's how it is that's why it's
a beautiful thing and it's a record of
discovery over the centuries mhm and I
love it so now for example the element
we discovered an element on the Sun
before we discovered it here on earth
okay and we named it after the Sun the
Sun God Helios helium which became
helium which is a lot of that in the Sun
oh yeah it's a temperate about 10% yeah
and we're running out of it on earth on
earth that's right that's right and so
helium is not uncommon in the universe
and because we keep filling like
Thanksgiving Day balloons with you all
days they would let it escape right and
then regenerate the helium but now they
recapture it I've been told today
because Macy's is the second biggest
consumer of helium in the world
get out here after the US military and
elem has very special properties not all
of which I can divulge get out really
yeah come on yeah ah like making you
talk funny cuz that's a Dutch dude
that's not a secret not a secret because
that's the best one by the way there's
an element that was missing and we did
the calculation after quantum physics
was discovered and we noticed that that
element is unstable so even if it was
ever in the universe it would have
decayed into something else by now so it
would be like a permanent gap never
cooked anything that was air was not
there now so we said well okay let's
just make it make the stuff so we
manufactured an element to fit in the
gap and we named it after ourselves we
named it after technology is called
technetium technetium yeah sweet oh man
and of course because we made it it
can't last but we named it tech yeah
Tech means that looks artificial yeah
and in fact technetium is a very active
tool potent tool for the radiologist
because if you you can set it up in
waste at different half-lives that's six
hours or ten hours you can do
experiments with you know your your your
circulatory system by tracking the
radioactivity and if small amounts are
okay if it can right now you can trace
it as it moves as it will the half-life
and it'll go away and go out to where
you've done you leave the hospital
you're done right yeah that is brilliant
I was once in a hospital with one of my
radiation detectors which I occasionally
carry and only you was almost this Oh
sat down next to me in the waiting room
and the alarm started going off and I
looked to the person I said okay what
are you in for well I just did it they
just did a radioactive dye test on right
and he was still radioactive for as he
would be for the next few hours
so I moved to another chair this is
Startalk